aquí tenemos esta maqueta que está hecha
para mostrar cómo funciona otra parte
del circuito enciendo lo interruptor y
puedes ver que ambos motores giran en
esta dirección los motores están jalando
corriente eléctrica de la batería que
está corriendo en los motores haciendo
que éstos giren en esta dirección
puedes ver que el cable de la tierra
está conectado al cable azul que va
directo a los motores luego la conexión
va hacia el interruptor que está
conectado a lado positivo de la batería
y cuando tenemos ese tipo de cableado
hacemos que los motores giren en esa
dirección
ahora nota que el cable positivo no está
conectado no lo necesitamos porque
estamos usando este cable amarillo para
la conexión con las baterías y solo
necesitamos una batería para que ambos
motores funcionen porque una batería
tiene 1.5 volts y eso es suficiente para
hacer que los motores giren por lo que
solo usaremos esta batería para el giro
de los motores y el giro de los motores
es hacia atrás como puedes ver
ahora aquí tenemos otra configuración
tenemos otra versión de la maqueta
porque queremos que los motores giren
hacia adelante y hacia atrás y con esta
configuración los motores giran hacia
adelante
es decir giran en esta dirección y
observa que ya coloque la batería del
otro lado y también observa que estamos
conectando al cable positivo en lugar
del cable negativo el cable negativo no
lo necesitamos porque tenemos este cable
amarillo que sale de aquí entonces lo
que hicimos fue cambiar la orientación
de la pila y así la corriente eléctrica
corre en la otra dirección ocasionando
que los motores giran hacia adelante es
decir si tú revierte es la dirección en
que corre la electricidad podrás cambiar
la dirección de giro de los motores